foreign
Leslie
welcome to the show
hi um thank you for taking my call so
the reason for my call today was in my
senior year of high school I was working
a bunch of jobs I saved up a bunch of
money to buy my first car and to pay for
college I would say I saved about three
thousand dollars at the time and because
I was 17 a minor my mom was like the
owner of my account essentially so she
had access to it and she asked me to
borrow three thousand dollars and
because I've been watching Dave Ramsey
since I was like 16 I knew that was a
dumb idea so I said no but because she
had access to my account she went ahead
and took that money out anyways and then
a couple months later she never paid me
back
a couple months later she went to a
police auction and bought a unregistered
car that failed the Minnesota safety
exam twice so it was unsafe to drive and
then she forced me to spend another 2
000 on repairing this car because like I
said it wasn't drivable so I'm just kind
of in a rut right now like I don't know
what to do about my next vehicle how old
are you
um I'm 18 years old so this was a year
ago was this this past 12 months this
was a year ago and even though the car
was unsafe to drive I was still driving
it almost actually got an accident so
recently I just stopped driving it so I
don't drive right now what is the
current relationship with your mom
um so we try to maintain a good
relationship aside from like just the
financial aspect of this I would say I'm
really hurt on an emotional level yeah
that that you have every right to be
that's a lot so you said there was the
original 3000 and then you said she
forced you to do the additional 2000 how
did that happen
well she bought it without my consent
right like she she took um she bought
this car for fifteen hundred dollars
bought it without my consent
um never gave me my 3 000 back and
because
um you know she had access to my account
she pulled another two thousand dollars
out of my account to fix this car so how
and also um sorry um I forgot to mention
she also suggested that I take out
student loans to buy a car and mind you
I'm on full academic scholarships right
now so I have no loans and she suggested
that I should take out student loans to
get a car
how have these conversations with your
mom gone you said you still have a a
decent relationship but you anybody in
your situation I just want to stop for a
second and validate would feel
emotionally hurt that is a very hurtful
thing but just like the money aside I'm
just so disappointed that the person
who's supposed to protect me would even
do this
where are you living now
um I live on campus okay I go to the
University of Minnesota are you working
uh yes I do and are your finances now
separated from your mom like she as soon
as I turned 18 on my 18th birthday I
didn't even have a party I went to the
bank get it girl well before we even
dive any further we'll make sure you
stay on the line after this call we're
gonna get you a copy of own your past
change your future by Dr John deloney
because you've got a lot to sort through
you've got the financial part and that's
just incredibly hurtful you're grieving
the loss of the finances but really the
loss of this relationship because you
can't trust mom anymore and that's what
every relationship is based on
yeah what's worse is if I even bring up
like how disappointed I am she's like
well if it wasn't because of me you
wouldn't even have a car you're so
ungrateful I've done so much for you I
gave birth to you you don't even know
what I'm going through I really needed
that money she must be going through
something does she have any addictions
does she have big spending problems
she has a very bad spending problem and
her and my dad are going through some
marital problems too so that doesn't
help well I would also so just to lay
the very Foundation you said you're at
college I would see if there's a mental
health office at your college where you
can see a counselor because right now
you're going through a lot of
manipulation there's a lot of turmoil
right now the relationship with your mom
is not healthy and you know that but
it's hard because it's your mom it's a
primal wound you feel that draw towards
your mom you want her in your life right
we all want to have those types of
relationships this isn't healthy and I
think it will help you to have some
outside consistent consultation where
somebody can go you you are valid and
being mad about this like this is
hurtful but then also to help separate
this is hurtful this is your past but
how are we going to move forward in the
future how are you going to get rid of
those wounds and those hurts so that you
can move forward with your life in a
healthy way so Leslie how much money do
you have right now
um I have about four thousand dollars in
my savings account right now that she
does not have access okay good we're
gonna see how much we can get for your
current car it may be pennies and we're
gonna get you a safe car and if you can
borrow one for now ride around with
friends that's what I'm doing around
campus for now but what a sad situation
I'm so sorry for what you have gone
through you're gonna climb out of this
thing and it's gonna be a stupid tax and
it's not your fault but it's your
responsibility on what you do moving
forward thanks for the call